we just need to cut back now like wasted
the economic development agency in the
export-import bank that's become little
more than a fund for corporate welfare
created by Franklin Roosevelt the
export-import bank gives taxpayer backed
loans loan guarantees and credit
insurance to foreign companies seeking
to buy products from US manufacturers
the bank which is colloquially known as
XM is notorious for inefficiency
ineffectiveness and sloppy accounting
it's coming up for reauthorization later
this year and for the first time in a
long time opponents have a real shot at
ending the program here are three
reasons to kill the export-import bank
forever just imports no exports he's an
importer exporter okay in 2012 alone XM
authorized 36 billion dollars in loans
guarantees and insurance the bank can
carry a portfolio of up to 150 billion
dollars meaning that taxpayers could be
on the hook for that much money just
imports no exports he's an importer
exporter ok according to the Merc a
dissenters veronique to russia ex-im's
favored firms account for only 2% of the
total dollar value of American exports
and just 2% of the jobs associated with
exports just imports no exports
he's an importer exporter okay although
XM's defenders like to claim the bank
levels the international playing field
for small US companies virtually all of
the agency's resources go to supporting
giant politically connected firms such
as Boeing General Electric Caterpillar
and John Deere the American taxpayer
shouldn't be subsidizing their market
share at home or abroad the new House
Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy has said
he's against reauthorizing the
export-import bank
I think Exim Bank is one that something
government does not have to be involved
in the private sector can do it he's
joined by representatives and Senators
on both sides of the aisle who are
offended by the uselessness and cronyism
of XM hopefully this is one New Deal era
policy that will finally disappear for
good for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie